hi everyone i'd like to welcome you to
inf300 and thank you for joining us
today for this cloud next session
exploring gce vm families
today we're going to start by giving you
an overview of the gcevm families and
then we're going to have a deep dive
looking at each of these vm families to
see how they're tailored to meet the
needs of individual workloads
looking at our general purpose bm
families compute intensive vm families
memory optimized vms
and then finally options for running
accelerated workloads on google compute
engine
i'd like to start by introducing myself
i'm jamie kinney i'm a product manager
and i'm responsible for the tao t2d vm
family i joined google a little bit over
three years ago initially as a cloud
solutions architect focusing on both
scientific and technical computing and
also working with some of google cloud's
largest customers as they migrated their
cloud-native workloads to gce
subaru would like to introduce yourself
sure thanks jamie hey my name is subra
chandramauli i'm also a product manager
at google cloud covering google compute
engine products
my background has been primarily in the
semiconductor industry
focused on processors and fpga
accelerators
for data center markets including
amongst others
thanks everybody
okay just to kick things off i'd like to
start with an overview of what gce is so
gce or google compute engine is google
cloud's managed service for offering
virtual machines as a service with gce
you can easily choose a vm that meets
your needs
either selecting one of our predefined
shapes or custom defining your own
following our recommendations if you
like or if you have exact specifications
you can dial in that vm to precisely
meet your needs
gce also takes care of a lot of the
operational overhead of running
applications
offering technologies like live
migration for example which will allow
us to easily move your virtual machine
to a server while we perform maintenance
on a machine that might need some
assistance
we can also give you a number of
mechanisms to reduce the cost of running
your workloads when you run on top of
google compute engine with features like
sustained use discounts that
automatically provide discounts for
long-running applications
or if you'd like to get even deeper cost
savings you can look at our one-year and
three-year committed use discounts
today our focus is going to be on gce vm
families and how to choose the right
family for the needs of a given workload
just to provide a little bit of history
on google compute engine we initially
launched the service back in
june of 2012
and at that time google compute engine
offered just a single type of virtual
machine
over the past nine years on top of that
single vm family we also built a number
of features things like live migration
the ability to attach persistent disk
and other features that make those
virtual machines even more capable and
powerful and better fit for your
applications and their needs
in recent years we've expanded the
number of virtual machine families that
are offered by google compute engine to
include compute optimized memory
optimized accelerated workload optimized
vms and even more general purpose vm
families
today we're going to look in into each
of these vm families and see how they're
best applied
starting with a map to help you orient
yourself around the different vm
families that we offer
we generally divide these into two
high-level categories general purpose
pms and workload optimized vm families
on the general purpose side we have the
cost optimized vm families this includes
e2 and these are our vm families that
are designed to minimize the price per
vcpu
we also offer a balanced vm family that
gives you access to all of gce's
features the flexibility to attach local
ssds to attach
any of our persistent disk variants
access to the fastest networking
and the ability to dial in the custom vm
shapes
for customers that are running scaled
out workloads for a wide range of
applications be it
web serving application surveying or
even high throughput computing workloads
we've introduced a new category of vm
families designed to meet those needs uh
currently including the tile t2d vm
family that you'll be hearing more from
zubron
on the other side of this map you see
the workbook optimized vm families these
are vm families that are specifically
tailored to meet the needs of a possibly
niche or or a very well-defined set of
applications
this could include the compute optimized
vm family that's really well suited for
high performance computing game servers
and other compute intensive applications
memory optimized vms for
vertically scaled applications that need
access to large amounts of memory and
balanced compute to go with it and
accelerator optimized vms with tpus and
gpus to meet the needs of machine
learning and other workloads that
benefit from these specific accelerators
in addition to vm families google
compute engine as i mentioned over the
past several years has developed a
number of features that
provide even more value to your virtual
machine engines this includes things
like uh custom machine types the ability
to launch little tenant vms which we'll
talk about more later in the
presentation
the ability to attach various forms of
storage via local ssd or persistent disk
storage of various speeds and
capabilities
and also enhanced 100 gigabit networking
that delivers fantastically low latency
and the bandwidth needed for some of
your most demanding workloads
now i'd like to hand it off to subra to
give us a deeper dive on what we mean by
general purpose beyond families and talk
about the workloads and the families
that tend to go with those supra
hey thanks jamie
as jamie was alluding to one of our core
philosophies at google cloud is to
enable our customers the flexibility to
choose the right virtual machine
to run their various different workloads
general purpose workloads make up a
whole wide variety from simple web
serving to more complex media transcoder
processing types of workloads to data
analytics to name a few
we can also think of dev and test as a
separate workload that whose
requirements are pretty unique
in addition various enterprise
applications may be categorized under
the general purpose category as well
our general purpose n2 and n2d machine
types are a good fit for such workloads
our general purpose n2 and n2d vms are
designed to support a variety of
workloads by offering a perfect balance
of compute and memory resources up to
224 vcpus with 864 gigabytes of memory
end-to-end n2d machine types provide
high degree of flexibility for our
customers
custom machine types enable you to
right-size your resources enabling
great cost saving feature more on this
later
they also enable you to auto upgrade to
new cpu generations when we launch a new
cpu platform this means you can simply
choose a minimum
cpu platform and google will
automatically run your vm on the latest
generation cpu
you can also attach up to nine terabytes
of local ssd per node and you get high
networking performance up to 100
gigabits per second
these vms are also available globally
across gce regions now
the key difference between n2 and n2d
are summarized in the cable on the right
side of the slide
n2 vms are a general purpose intel
processor based vms supporting
second generation intel xeon scalable
processor or cascade lake and offering
vms that go up to atv cpus
the n2 n2 vms offer up to 20 to 30 price
performance improvements compared to n1
n2d
is our amd epic base general purpose vms
leveraging second generation amd epic
rom processors
they come with up to 224 vcpus per node
and offer you a lower price point with
approximately 13 percent lower pricing
compared to our n2 machine types
into vms are ideal for workloads that
require high per core performance
you can see some benchmarks that compare
into vms to our n1 vms on the right side
of the slide
n2 machines are priced at parity to n1
family enabling much higher price
performance when compared to our n1
machines
n2d machines
are ideal for high throughput workloads
that can benefit from having a large
number of threads
n2d machines are ideal for workloads
that may benefit from confidential
computing features in addition
switching gears
a bit
our e2 vm family are ideal for
applications where cost is a priority
e2 vms offer machine types up to 32
vcpus and 128 gigabytes of memory
we also offer the flexibility of
choosing custom machine types with our
e2 family
e2 family runs on intel haswell through
cascade lake and amd roam processors
e2 machines are ideal for dev and test
types of workloads or for workloads that
may be bash processed for example
this family provides
up to 31 cost saving when compared to
our n1 family per vm
switching gears again
earlier this year in june we announced
our latest
vm family under the brand of tau
the t2d is our first family of the first
family of vms that will be offered under
the tau brand
currently under preview tao vms are
designed to meet the needs of customers
learning scale out workloads on google
cloud
we chose the tau brand as a greek letter
tau is used to represent both torque and
the golden ratio
the tarc is a metaphor
that is apt because t2d vm family
allocates an entire physical core per v
cpu delivering excellent per thread
performance
while the golden ratio tower
represents t2d's focus on only core
features needed for scale out workloads
in order to deliver excellent price
performance
focusing on ttd's performance we can see
that it outperforms vm types available
elsewhere
here's a quick look at two benchmarks
where we showcase t2d's price
performance for estimated spec end and
core mark
for estimated spec end t2d provides 42
better price performance when compared
to other major cloud providers
back to you jamie
thanks zebra
now i'd like to take a look at compute
intensive workloads and i thought we
would start by giving you an overview of
what we mean by compute intensive
workloads
you know what live focused on scientific
and technical computing in the past
computer intensive workloads actually
fall under a number of verticals and
industries around the world
this includes workloads such as high
performance web servers that need access
to
fast clock speed cpus as well as the
networking that allows pages to be
served with incredibly low latency also
really important for aaa game servers
that need to both scale up vertically
but also ensure that there there's no
jitter that's that's being viewed as a
result of any inconsistencies in
performance with the cpu or network
variability
high performance computing near and dear
to my heart tends to fall into two
categories tightly coupled uh which will
usually rely on the latency networking
between the number of machines
and also high throughput computing that
relies on many machines working in
concert to solve a problem
uh where the uh per core performance of
those machines is it is going to
indicate how well that application runs
and a great example of a high throughput
computing workload is electronic design
automation or eda which needs access to
both fast cores but also a network that
makes it easy for all of those cores to
access
resources that are stored on a high
performance shared file system
in order to meet the needs of these
unique applications we've developed
compute optimized vms including the c2
family
that offer a combination of excellent
per core performance
consistent performance and also
isolation between virtual machines
the c2 vms as we can see here with
the benchmark results that compare c2 to
the n1 family
offer better per core performance offer
low latency high bandwidth networking
and
are really designed to meet the needs of
these unique applications
another element of the of the c2 family
is that the standard machine types for
c2 have a lower
memory per core ratio as these types of
applications tend to focus on
cpu needs as opposed to taking advantage
of large amounts of memory per core
speaking of memory per core they can now
transition over to the memory intensive
workloads
so this could include a number of
different types of applications it could
be an in-memory database like sap hana
it could be in-memory analytics olap
systems and other analytic systems that
need to keep data sets in memory for low
latency analysis and access as well as
in-memory caching that's common
components of many uh distributed and
cloud-native applications think of redis
or elastic for example
for these workloads the m1 and m2 vm
families are likely to be your best fit
uh m1 and m2 vms can offer up to 12
terabytes of memory while also offering
a large number of cores to go hand in
hand with that memory so that you're
able to analyze it at scale
the largest m2
ultra mem and megaman vms for example
offer over 400 cores or 400 vcpus per
virtual machine
these vm families also take advantage of
the fully flexible infrastructure
allowing you to adjust the cpu and
memory needs
provisioned to meet the needs of your
applications
and we also support the the provisioning
models including flex cuts that allow
your you to get discounts
when you're using all of our memory
optimized vm shapes both current and
future
now i'd like to transition us back to
another class of workloads these are the
accelerated workloads that need access
to gpus and tpus super would you like to
give us an overview of these workloads
and the bm families to go with them sure
thanks jamie
there are several workloads that can
take advantage of hardware gpu
acceleration
typically these are data intensive
workloads for instance you may have an
ai inference or a training type of a
workload
some of the training workloads could be
bursty but they have to deal with a lot
of data
in in a bursty mode or you can think of
a data analytics where you have massive
data coming through and you you have the
ability to
process the data parallely
gpus are a great fit for parallel
processing
other types of workloads that can take
advantage of gpu acceleration are high
performance computing and several video
intensive workloads
our a2vm family includes the latest
nvidia a100 gpus with up to 40 gigabytes
of memory
in these machine types we support up to
96 vcpus with 1.3 terabytes of memory
these machines come in various
predefined machine types with which
support up to 16 nvidia a100 gpus
delivering up to 10 petaflops of ffp16
performance or 20 petaflops of int 8
performance in a single vm
thanks super i really appreciate that um
in addition to each of the vm families
that we've mentioned uh we also have a
number of gce features that span
multiple vm families and that are
really going to be relevant to a broad
range of workloads we just want to touch
on a few of these today and i'd like to
start by talking about custom machine
types this is a feature that's unique to
google cloud and it's a feature that is
giving our customers significant cost
savings on average they're seeing 19
savings and in many cases they're seeing
substantially more than that custom
machine types as you can see in the
little slider or a diagram in the middle
of this allows you to precisely dial in
the cpu and memory that's allocated to
you to the vms that you're launching
within google compute engine
this is often applied in cases where the
standard machine types that we've
predefined
for ease of use and flexibility might
not meet your needs and where you need
to advocate perhaps a little bit more
memory or a little bit more cpu for your
workload
and by allowing you to tell us exactly
what you need we we don't over provision
those resources for you this allows us
to then uh reduce the cost of a google
compute engine and we pass those savings
back on to you
some additional gce features that also
benefit the the wide range of workloads
you might want to run google compute
engine include sole tenant nodes this is
most often applied for applications that
have licensing requirements that mandate
that you are the only customer or only
user running on it on a given physical
server
this old tenant knows you have access to
the entire machine and you have the
ability to carve it up into whatever vm
shapes you need
very helpful for
board applications that have those
specific licensing requirements
shielded vms are a feature that allow
you to ensure that your workloads are
running on untrusted and verified
hardware taking advantage of the
the tpm uh
efi firmware that we
that we're running on on gc
infrastructure
and uh confidential vms provide
additional isolation and sandboxing for
especially sensitive applications you
can read more about these
in some of the resources that we've
provided below accessing both the gce
documentation uh tutorials case studies
and other resources
we've also provided some links to
additional next sessions that you might
want to attend as well as a couple of
coursera courses for those of you who
might be new to google compute engine or
simply want to expand your familiarity
and understanding of our services
with that i'd really like to thank subra
for joining me today and most
importantly i'd like to thank you for
joining us and for listening to this
talk
i hope that it improved your
understanding of google compute engine
and i hope that the rest of your next
experience is a wonderful one have a
great day thanks
you